[Music]
welcome to games you should know by
hearts I'm Eric Grandmaster in residence
for the week I mean I am but I have the
GM doesn't struggle today we're gonna
look at a variety of games in the same
opening and it's one of my favorite
openings very popular at both beginner
level and higher levels
it's a London opening I know one one
person here it plays the London does
anyone else play the London as white
which is d4 usually d4 and Bishop f4
anyone maybe sometimes okay has anyone
played against the London is black I'm
sure if you've been playing chess for
some time you played London it's or
played against London at some point now
one thing about the London it has kind
of a solid but sort of boring reputation
where a lot of a lot of players just
don't like going into those sort of
positions as whites it might be just too
boring and they they go for some efore
opening which is more aggressive with
these games that I prepared I'm gonna
try and change the reputation of a
London try and show all of the exciting
possibilities so many exciting tracks
and then hopefully after this lecture
you'll at least be inspired to try out
the London opening at some point so the
first game I want to start with is
actually a game that I played on online
a few weeks ago and I usually don't do
this I was actually debating whether or
not to show this game this was a bollock
game on me chess bullet chess is one
minute chess I'm showing this game
because I used pretty much all of my
opening preparation it was maybe I don't
look like 12 13 years of opening
preparation and I won in under 15 months
another thing special about this game is
I was playing against a very strong
Grandmaster I'm not a hundred percent
sure it was a GN who I'm thinking about
or Who I am I was told but I'm pretty
sure it was against Bob you know Carl
and he was playing under I think someone
else's account and it was anonymous
accounts I'm not going to share that
count name but I know that it was I'm
pretty sure was Fabiano because after I
I played like all these bullet games I
got this the snapchats message on my
phone from Viviano and there's a picture
of of him and his friend is playing me
online and I will say I lost about 90 to
95 percent of the games this was one of
the few games I won and I only won this
game because of some dirty opening trick
so we're gonna go through with the game
d4 Knight of 6 and in this position I
played Bishop f4 I believe II 6 III and
for any any beginners London opening is
incredibly easy to play or at least to
learn from the very GetGo if I'm
teaching London to maybe some some newer
players usually a light show is you just
want to put your pieces like so put your
pawn on c3 Knight on g2 and like ghost
f3 Bishop goes to d3 at Castle and if
you do this it's hard to go wrong and
you can do this against most setups at
black juices and then it's a very
difficult opening to crack even for
stronger players in this game I'm going
to show some more kind of high low
higher level stuff against black
specific setup so I started with he
started with c5 I played Knight f3 and
then he played b6 and b6 is a very
common move especially among a lot of
stronger players just aiming to be solid
looking to play something like Bishop e7
control the long diagonal maybe play
some move like Knight to Knight to c6 it
has a solid reputation but there's some
tricks to be aware of from the black
perspective and in this position I play
the very tricky move pawn c4 and the
idea behind this move is I want to play
d5 and I want just want to gain space in
the center and if I achieve d5 then it
sort of transforms into what we call the
benoni opening
which is usually Pleasant edge for white
just having more space so what was
played here as black Bishop e7 was
played which looks like it prevents d5
this black is now controlling d5 three
times pawn bishop Knights
however I've studied this position
before and there's a very cool trick
that white can use in this position I
can play d5 anyway and it's a pawn
sacrifice by stacking upon but getting a
lot of initiative as you'll see so back
when I had clicked upon and in this
position I play Knight c3 and very
important theme in this game is I didn't
really care about material I cared about
accelerating development and then very
quickly attacking black so we're gonna
go forward pawn takes e4 black is
currently up to pawns I could take back
on c4 it if I want went back one plum
but there's a more powerful move here
started with Knight to d5 and in this
position black is already having some
threats to deal with the obvious threat
is night c7 and there's not too many
ways to defend against the threat and in
this position I think Fabiana played
maybe a careless move I mean it was
bullet so you're not gonna play the most
accurate moves let me show the best move
here and let me show coming like cool
preparation because it's very easy for
blacks position to completely collapse
even if the best move is played so best
move is night a6 just defending c7 and
then white can very happily capture on
c4 and now in this position there's a
really attractive move for black which
I'll just show which is d5 and it looks
like black is basically solving all the
problems expanding the center attacking
the bishop d6 is no longer weak in this
position what it has a really cool move
which I'll leave it up to you guys to
find white to move and basically find
the winning move if white doesn't play
this move it's probably worse for lights
so very important moments sorry yeah
Queen a4 it's a beautiful move we ignore
the fact that the bishops attacked and
we just go for a counter play and in
this case queen a4 causes some really
serious threats against the king
next he signs of threat 96 as a threat
black has no time to capture NC 4 so
there's actually a game played in this
position I believe between Azaria and
Knight itch and Knight each played 97
and in this position white didn't follow
up correctly White has another very
strong move here I think white played 95
if I'm not mistaken Osorio is white 95
was played white actually went on to
lose the game so I want to show the
strongest move in this position from
whites there is uh there's a really
beautiful sort of combination which
starts with a pretty incredible move
Jocelyn Queen side again ignoring the
fact the ship is attacked on c4 and
bringing the rook to the D file and
what's amazing is after or if black
tries to capture the Bishop White's
gonna go ahead and capture on d7 and
it's incredible because white sacrifice
is a c4 Bishop sacrifices the rook on g7
but after Queen take d7 and then 95 in
box position was just completely
collapsing the Queen would have to move
off of this diagonal and then there's
going to be some very nasty discover
checks against the King on Yeats so I'm
actually not going to go forward here
because there's a bunch of options if
anyone wants to analyze this later
do so in your own time but White's just
completely crushing here I think's
doctor says like plus 6 plus 7 so let's
go back I will say I've had this
position in one game and it was some
like casual game or like online blitz
game but I'm showing the Fabiano game or
the supposed father
game because our finish was pretty cool
as well so instead of 96 he played not
such such a good move t6 I didn't
realize it I could still play Queen a4
here Queenie a4 is still a good move I
went ahead
I took the pawn first on g6 then he
plays my day six defending c7 I went
ahead I took on c4 and then he played 94
so trying to get some some attack at
least against the bishop trying to
remove the Bishop from d6 however
because I was familiar with the other
line which I just showed
I knew that Queen a4 is just such a
thematic idea and I played it without
too much thought in this position
because he's discovered attacks are just
so so menacing against the king and
after Queen d7 there is a completely
crushing move for whites white to move
what's the easiest move to play 97 check
97 Knight takes you 795 yeah
95 very direct attacking the Queen
attacking f7 White's basically using all
the pieces and even yeah even the Queen
on a4 thanks for playing that and that's
that's some one of the issues for
lacking an opening like this is if white
gets all the pieces into play before
black can get the King safe it can be
very very dangerous so this position is
just I'd lost I just want to show you
the finish the finish was pretty
beautiful black plague rook e8 and I
could go ahead and take the Queen and
probably end up winning however white to
move force made in two moves
aha Bishop f7 and the final mate was
pretty nice double check needs a queen
queen and the knight both attacking the
king the king has nowhere to go
okay so that was kind of a fuel good
game didn't really count for anything
but it's cool - supposedly play like the
top five player in the world and win
like this it's maybe worth losing the
other 95% of the games we're gonna move
on I want to go to actually a very
classic game between God account Sookie
Sam Jenkins I'm sure most people here
have heard of at least one of these
players hopefully both Golikov Sookie is
probably the most well known player at
the top level for consistently playing
the London it's been his main weapon of
choice before it was cool sort of a
hipster in some regard I actually played
Tomsky in some blitz tournament many
years ago he crushed me with the London
and he's found some really interesting
and innovative ideas so this is one of
the cooler games that he played which
features some really nice opening
preparation and this is actually one of
the games which inspired me to play the
London so sometimes all it takes is one
cool game to inspire someone to play an
opening so like to share that with you
guys we're gonna go forward and I want
you guys to know this in this game
chomsky does a complete exact setup
which I mentioned earlier which I teach
most beginners he just puts his pieces
on kind of the the very typical London
squares so in light of three now I
should mention this is the first kind of
decision moment for whites where black
does challenge this Bishop on f4 and
White has a few choices here white could
take on d6 what could ignore the threat
like a play Bishop g3 if you're a London
player and you're getting in this
situation a lot the the most principled
move is to play Bishop g3 and that's
what cops do us you don't want to
concede the trade of bishops on g6
because that would help activate the
black queen
and when you play Bishop g3 you make it
so that if black takes on g3 you're very
happy to open H file and it's actually a
mistake for luck I've had a lot of a lot
of blitz games which have gone down this
path after black castles white plays
Bishop d3 and white actually gets some
very quick attack because the rook on
the open H file and the bishop they
coordinate very well and I've actually
had games where black maybe plays h6
trying to defend and then I can continue
with a move like ninety five ideas of g4
g5 as very fun for for whites and in
these situations light won't usually
Castle kingside because you want the
rook to stay on each file anyway let's
go back because and in this game
Shanklin did not take on g3 he played
the main line which is castling comps
key completes development Bishop d3 and
this is one of the most common lines in
the London I'm sure hundreds if not
thousands of games have reached this
exact position and there's a lot of
theory surrounding it very popular at
the top levels and in this position
Shanklin has played a very natural
intuitive move he started with Queen e7
and it's very important to understand
the purpose behind Queen e7 black wants
to play e5 here gain space so if y it
ignores the threat and just castles and
black plays e5 black should be very
happy so if we go back after Queen e7
white house it really important to move
here to stop e5 and that move is very
simply 95 and this is a very common
London move where you put you're not an
e5 you have ideas of maybe playing f4 or
maybe even the other knights after me
it's one of these moves which can allow
your in your position to improve further
so in this position 95 was played
Shanklin what I had he played 97 and now
we're actually walking into kind of a
very interesting tactical line let me
put
listen training mode what's about to
happen is the next MMA b-78 moves are
completely forcing and what's going to
happen is at the very end of kind of the
combination whites gonna be practically
winning I will note it's not completely
forcing there there are some ways for
black to to not lose but I'm just gonna
go ahead and just play through the
natural moves first might take g7 this
should take t7 very natural bishop take
g6 queen take you six again very natural
pawn dixie 520 takes e5 and we reach
this position it just seems like things
have kind of looked liquidated time
simplified seems like kind of a very
balanced equal position equal material
not too many weaknesses for both sides
before I go any further because anyone
know this position anyone's seen this
position before you see you okay so most
experienced London London players should
have at least seen this before and this
is a really really famous position
because white has a completely
unexpected combination starting with the
next move that's a good question I don't
think so I think there is maybe one
person before this but I think after
this game there is some like blog blog
article and then like everyone realized
like the track so anyone who hasn't seen
this before you want to try and find the
combination white to move I'm realizing
this is actually pretty tough if you've
never seen this before
it could take a while on so Alex do you
want to say the move h7 and I'm sure if
you've maybe studied like tactics you've
seen what we call the Greek gift
sacrifice where you stack on h7 and you
get some attacking against the King it
seems like in this position Bishop take
h7 shouldn't work but it does work for a
very cool reason so let's go forward can
you take h7
Queen age 5 check King g8 and incredibly
important move here 94 and it's
incredible but the Queen on H 5 pins
upon meanwhile the night attacks the
Queen and I can't be taken and why is
threatening both the Queen and Knight g5
so White's wasting no time
every moves a threat black screen has to
move and after Knight g5 white is
actually very close to me so it's really
really difficult for black to the friend
in this position and actually white
pretty much already has it decisively
managed now we're gonna go forward the
game's not over but if you play the
London this is such a devious trap and
it's the type of thing that even strong
players don't know about like this game
sands England over 2600 just walked into
it's not every day a strong GM walks
into a trap like this so we're gonna go
forward Queen and see 495 and it still
took work for a white to convert blocks
not getting mated yet because rip d8
however white is happy to win that side
and bond and after this white plays
Queen age 5 team g8 now let me explain
because there's some interesting kind of
nuanced ideas without to best convert
this position and I do want to explain
the line that white would like to play
is Queen h7 King f8 Queen h8 this is
well forcing here here and then king b6
and it looks good for whites like you've
won the g7 pawn you got the King to d6
but the King's kind of escaping and
things might become unclear because
black does have the extra bishop
so Kamsky uh of course realize this and
played a really really important move in
this position take rook t1 he's in no
rush to play Queen h7 Swedish 7 can
basically be played any time he wants
first she's preparing his attack by
putting the rook on d1 so if the King
ever comes to d6
Brook will be on the best where so we're
gonna see how the game continues black
lady five trying to do something I guess
control more center and then white plate
Queen f7 key mutates and now another
nice move from lights Pawnee four and
you know this white wants to to try and
open the D file if the D file opens and
d6 will be cut off and the King won't
have in escape routes oh we should also
notice the point can't take on e4 cuz
there's a pin so the pawn is pinned to
the Queen from behind and why it's
already like very close to winning here
and if you like take time and you look
in this position for black it's really
hard to find a move here for black black
is pretty restricted so what happened in
the game Shanklin tried to sacrifice
back at piece and get counter play but
it didn't work out and really there is
no no other like useful thing he could
have done so we'll just see what
happened he played ninety seven giving
away in the night which calms he gladly
took and then Shanklin had the
initiative for maybe like two to three
moves but it didn't last so he played
the ship e5 threatening means it's
slightly scary because black bear
White's King is stuck in the center
why can't castle but calm ski very
calmly plays rook d2 Shanklin takes on a
two and I really like the handling from
white in this position because it like
all the moves are just so calm like he's
not scared of Queen B one Czech happy to
allow Queen B one check
he simply moves back to f7 so he
realizes if he can do the same thing
Queen Queen h5 check we need seven check
and if the king ever comes to d6 there's
going to be a much stronger follow up so
Queen a1 was played rook t1 Queen take
b2 again threatening mate but now white
is just in time to say grab the
initiative before black inmate so the
rest of the game just a series of checks
Queen h5
seven queen eight shades queen take g7
and now we see the importance of that
rook t1 move now the rook is in prime
position rook takes d5 King keeps
running and then Queen f6 was the last
move and then black resigns really no
hope here like all of whites pieces are
coming into action if we want to play on
a few more moves I can just show you
what would happen after Queen f6 black
would drop back white brings a knight in
and then okay this position is just
completely over like king b6 you could
you could take the rook with discovery
check you can play Knight d4 when the
bishop lots of ways to convert for
whites so this is a this very beautiful
opening preparation it's not every day
you can like get a strong opponent into
preparation and then just win kind of
right from the opening but that's what
happens sometimes when you play con ski
you'd be careful I have a bunch of games
to look at I want to start with kind of
a series of three games which all
feature the same trap I'm not gonna show
all three but I'll just show you one and
then you'll kind of get the sense by
making a point there are three games
here because they were all played by the
same player in same exact trap against
pretty strong players anyone know Ashwin
Jai Ram from the Webster team still
lives in st. Louis so we have kind of an
inside joke on the Webster team that
there's an opening trap names at the
Ashwin trap because he's had this in
three like serious games two of which
were the same exact tournament two which
happened at spice Club against against
offense so I want to make you guys aware
of this trap it used to be a secret now
it's I think it should be more public
especially after this video and the I
guess we'll start with the Josh polis
game this is this was the shortest game
and Osman played the London
if anyone knows Josh pretty strong
player FM has one GM norm but
unfortunately for Josh he didn't
understand or didn't know the opening in
this game and got worse very quickly so
we're gonna go forward London if you
know this it's the same opening as as a
Carolina game and earlier I showed c-4
in this game it turns out there's
another trap for whites which starts
with Knight bTW - and I think before we
called it the ostrich trap we just
called it the Knight d2 trap before
Ashwin
put his name on it 92 very tricky move
order and the idea is to actually punish
Bishop b7 and Bishop e7 is a move that
most players will play without even
thinking just very natural fee and color
of the bishop that's why black played b6
earlier however after Bishop e7 is
there's some really nice tactical and
position ideas for whites all starts
with Knight to c4 and this is not
something you see every day in a London
than like coming to c4 so early in this
position it's justified because d6 is
actually a pretty big weakness simply
threatening 96
I shouldn't note I had one game listen
random player they played d6 doesn't
work at all because a plum take C 5 and
then d6 is attacked three times 96 is
coming so most players in this position
will realize d6 is weak and they'll play
d5
oh four times including the fun right I
forgot about the fun yes so even if like
the pawn gets captured it's still three
times its that's enough I'm not the best
at counting sometimes anyway ninety five
and turns out once this position is
reached Black has already fallen into
the trap so I want to ask you guys in
this position what is whites threats
what does white want to play next move
this should be five anyone agree hope
some people agree there should be 5
check that's 1 threats and it's kind of
an interesting phenomenon but most
people will identify one threat here and
then miss another threat turns out in
this position white has two threats
Knight g5 and even strong players who
have reached this position it's it's
funny but though they'll see Bishop b5
or they'll see Knight g5 but they don't
acknowledge both it's very common a
common type of process in chess always
look for your pawns threat in this case
black has to look for both threats
unfortunately for black it's hard to
stop with Bishop e5 and Knight g5 what
happened in in this game Josh played c4
completely missing that g5 and the rest
of the game I mean the box position
collapses f7 can't be defended I'm just
gonna play through without too much
commentary like just one upon the knight
doesn't get trapped came to d6
it was pretty brutal and this game has
to maybe be rated like pg-13 anyway so
that was one game Austrian played real
quick we'll look at some other games
same tournament this was spice Cup last
year last year and maybe two years ago I
forget 2016 ok last year played against
Joel ba Noah who I think is an IM now
same trap 92 night see for 95 in this
game Joel played a decent try
you play night bd7 unfortunate this move
runs into both Bishop e5 and then the
eventual Knight g5 so if we look at what
Osman does Bishop e5 a6 and now actually
very important move here from lights you
don't want to move the bishop but you
you just play Knight g5 and you you're
gonna win you're gonna win f7 and what
happened the game after a a p5 take
Queen CA to take it looks like the
knight should get trapped in the corner
but the night usually manages to escape
and then white will just be up to
exchange white won the rook gave away
the bishop another another pretty much
decisive advantage
bye-bye move 10 I know the full
playthrough I don't know if Ashwin's
conversion was best here but you'll
notice he he just stayed up material and
okay another sort of brutal position for
black rook h3 nice move okay maybe some
some technical challenges for whites but
always held onto the extra exchange and
that was enough in the end okay we won't
go any further
one more game from ashwin this game was
a pro chesley game very quick hope you
guys aren't sick of this by now but in
this game a six was played again missing
Knight g5 we're not going to go any
further this was a an IM playing this
game kesef is this wanna da so I'm
showing this to you guys because this is
a great way to beat maybe some FM's or
IMS maybe even GM's who aren't well
informed in the opening especially this
line because I will say if we go back
like this this whole setup with b6 is
very common among stronger players but
for some reason stronger players don't
really know the exact traps in the
position or at least based on this game
say they don't know
okay so we're gonna move on from Ashwin
and look at another character in the
chess world I'm actually going to show
another one of my games I usually try
and avoid showing my games but this one
was pretty notable I played this over
the summer back in was it late July in
Denmark I did like this whole Europe
trip this is the last remnant of my trip
and I had the the great honour of
playing a seaman Agda Steen
I know if I'm saying that correctly but
has anyone heard of him
anyone yeah former coach of Magnus
Carlsen I think he has a brother Espen
who's Carlson's manager seaman is a
really interesting guy because he I mean
he's very strong Grandmaster over 2600
feet a and he also has played like
professional soccer for Norway he was
also in chess the musical and I didn't
realize this before I played him but
he's actually featured in a music video
maybe I'll show you guys after after
this lecture I won't show it now but
like a day or two after I played him
there's a music video and he's just
singing about Magnus Carlsen and it's a
really well produced video but it's a
really annoying song yeah so so anyway
it was cool together chance to play him
it was even cooler to beat him and a
nice game in the London so I'll show you
it was sort of a maybe somewhat atypical
line but I think it featured some really
nice kind of creative ideas so we'll
jump into it I was white another London
he played nine of six and then c5 and I
think I maybe showed I showed some
similar lines in a different lecture
where I recommended that like that black
plays in early c5 an attempt to play
Queen b6 and this is one of the main
drawbacks of the London let's say say
Knight f3
take take Queen b6 where black is
targeting the b2 pond
and this is sometimes like the worst I
don't want to say nightmare but kind of
the most unpleasant thing a london
player can can encounter because it's a
one-week point in whites position
because the bishop on f4 developed so
early
and as wait you don't usually want to
play kind of a consent conceding move to
the Fen b2 are usually you don't want to
play b3 you don't really want to play
Queen c1 so I want to show like the one
of the best ways to meet Queen b6 and
the best way to meet this move is with
aggression to go for counter play and
actually in many cases to sacrifice a
pawn so there's a very thematic move
here from from whites which I'll just go
ahead and show its Knight to c3 and the
idea is that if Queen take b2 white
happily gives away the pawn queen take
b2 is actually a blunder white to move
in this position what's the point
any idea oh you wanted to play b3
earlier you said b3 oh yeah yeah b3
earlier it's completely fine but Knight
c3 is better because it's um it's
developing and it makes it bad for Locke
to take on b2 so there's a really cool
move here from lights
95 very nice and what you're doing I
guess twofold first of all you're
threatening xe7 secondly you're in some
way kind of restricting the Queen from
coming back there's even some lines
where the Queen could get trapped on
meet you
so there's a there's a line here I'll
show it pretty quickly but if 96
defending c7 the best line for white is
rook b1 you give away the a pawn I'm
stalling someone this earlier but when
you give away pawns you open files and
in this case you put the rook back on a1
Queen goes back to b2 and there's a few
winning loose here for whites maybe the
simplest is just to take on a6 and then
play Knight c7 then when the rook
I think the stockfish move is just to
play Bishop d3 and then idea is just to
castle Queen e2 rook F 1 and this Queen
has a very hard time escaping from from
White's territory so this is something
that black usually just avoids so if you
play Knight c3 it's usually unlikely
that though they'll take on B - if they
see might be 5 so the next few moves
were really interesting because mo black
did he was trying to to make it so he
could take on me - he played the move
Bishop d7 here controlling the b v
square and it looks like that he wants
to take on b2 next which he does because
I'm like I wouldn't be able to play
Knight b5 so I came up with another move
here which kind of defends upon but with
tactics well I allow block to take the
pawn but if he takes the pawn it's
bathroom so move I play is 95 and this
feature is a slightly different but
similar idea where if he takes the pawn
it's still a mistake anyone want to
guess and move here for whites I heard
in 97 there's a stronger move
I mean I'll go ahead and show it still
might be fine and I will note that I was
out of my preparation pretty early in
this game I was probably out of
preparation around Knight c3 but I still
knew like a lot of like thematic ideas
that that kind of helped me figure out
the tactics so when I played 95 I
actually calculated kind of a long and
kind of a nice-looking line which I'll
go ahead and show 95 he would probably
take on b5 and then I play truck me one
I win back the piece however it's still
a little bit complicated he has Queen c3
check but then I played Bishop d2 making
sure it's Queens still attacked I can
still take on d5 if he takes on d4 I
take on b5 with check and I did give
away I give away the the b-pawn and the
D pawn so I'm down to pawns but I get
kind of an overwhelming attack and what
would happen here is probably something
like 97 I would trade and then take on
b7 and earlier when I played 95 I
calculated to this position and actually
I think I saw one move further that if
he plays King c8 there's very a nice
looking tactical idea of rook c7 where
the King can't it can't move to dark
square or can't move to c7 because
Bishop a5 and I would win the Queen so
this whole line is just bad for black
again so there's an interesting use of
tactics too instead of like going for
passive defense I go for a lot more
aggressive play with 95 ok so 95 I think
he took awhile here like he was probably
calculating Queen take b2 but probably
realized like all the dangers so he
played another move attempting to take
on V 2 he played a 6 now completely
stopping Knight b5 and clearly wanting
to take on b2 but as we'll see kind of
the theme was I don't defend me too I
just make it so that so that if he takes
it it's just a bad move so I play Queen
d2
oh no I didn't like Queens you two I
play Queen f3 even more aggressive and
if he does take on b2 in this case I
don't have night b5 but my Knights
defended which is really important
because then I can just move my rook and
I have ripped you one here and then if
he grabs c2 I grab b7 I think this is a
very nice looking position for white
active rook his queen that looks scary
but it's really not doing too much so he
didn't take on b2 yet again he played a
6 normal move I Castle we're gonna go
forward for a few moves might see 6 I
took on c6 he took and then I play g4 g
4 it's actually a very natural attacking
move especially because I'm Castle
queenside I would like to expand on the
Kings side now I have ideas of g5 try
and kick his night he went ahead he
played Queen a5 his idea he wants to
play 94 distract my knight from
defending a2 and then try and target a2
so if you listen to any Ben Feingold
lectures what move ya always play King
b1 probably the best move there
defending a to reinforcing a 2 so if the
nice deflected it's not a big problem
he went ahead he played b5 I played
Bishop t3 completing development and one
thing about this game was I think I
developed a bit quicker than him and
that allowed me to get the advantage of
it later on so he went ahead he played
b4 just expanding further 92 and in this
position I think he made this first like
kind of big error yeah he played 94 I'll
try and explain why this was a bad move
what he should have done was like Queen
b6 and try and push well he played the
game 94 the the bad thing about this
move is he was going all in too quickly
he was trying to go for for a quick
attack his clear idea was Knight c3
and I realized he was in a situation
where I can actually provoke him to be
over ambitious to overextend and then
and then capitalize later so I think
it's it's best to understand this by
just showing what happened in the game I
played Knight G 393 was a very kind of a
nerve-racking move to play because I'm
moving a piece away from potentially
defending my Kings side and I'm leaving
him with a potential to play Knight c3
and opened up my King and get a very
scary looking attack when I played this
move I realized he was in a situation
where he either has to sack is Knight or
retreat because I have three attackers
on e4 and it was actually a very
difficult situation for him and I think
he took maybe 20 to 30 minutes just
thinking about his next move
I could see like he was already not
happy with his situation and then
finally he went ahead and he played
Knight c3 and even though I was pretty
sure this didn't work for black I was I
still had to be very careful cuz it's so
scary like I have to take the Knights I
don't take the knight a to falls I take
the Knights he takes back and my King's
wide open he has his Queen to Bishop
rook and my pieces maybe don't seem like
the best in the best places for the Fen
however there is enough defensive
resources for whites and the rest of the
game is pretty much white first of all
fending off the attack and then
attacking against black King and the
game ended very quickly
it was should ends like around 25 move
25 so first stage defend king a king a1
making sure there's no like quick mates
he wanted to play Queen B for Queen B -
I'm also preparing rook b1 so he went
ahead he played Bishop a3 preparing to
play Bishop e2 I play rook e1 and
because he sacrificed tonight I'm
completely okay giving up material to
save my king and that's what happened he
played Bishop b2 he won the exchange
because I had to take he takes
and now we're in a situation where I
have I have two pieces for Brooke now
this is an important position most
experienced players will play the right
move without even thinking in this
position but wait to move the question
is should you take the pawn and should
you play King d1 yes yes yeah fine fine
gold would be happy in this case what
you're doing you're using the b-pawn as
a shield the the b-pawn is actually
acting as a defender so it it closes the
file so after King v1 there's no sort of
like Queen before check and I just leave
the partner I'm pretty sure the pawn
stayed there for the rest of the game
and my king is now it can breathe easily
there's no night to like come to c3 and
I mean while I have the minor pieces and
one thing about the situation when you
have like two pieces two minor pieces
for a rook is the minor pieces are much
more effective in the middle game than a
rook can be especially when there's no
like like critical open files and
especially when there's Queens on the
board and the strategy for white is just
to create an attack with the Queen and
the minor pieces and ultimately there
should be more attacking resources for
white than defending resources for black
so the game ended like very smoothly
just show you what happened castle and
it's a bad sign when like most of my
pieces are already on the Kings side
most of ox pieces are on the Kings side
or on the Queen side I went how do I
play g5 threatening Queen h5 there's
actually a really cool tactical sequence
here which he stopped he played f5 I do
just want to show if he plays some move
I don't know some random let's say rook
c8 I was ready to play Queen h5 g 6 and
then queen h6 and there's an unstoppable
threat I believe it's unstoppable of
Knight h5
and the point is 95 there's just too
many mating ideas g7 if you were to take
then each seven would be attacked so
just to show you one potential checkmate
let's say queen bee 4 9 h 5 she's also
note Knight f6 right let's say take then
we take on each 7 this is a classic
mating idea well I could play Bishop e5
here too I could also play this this m8
so he had to do had to do something with
all my pieces coming into action so he
played that five unfortunate I think
it's already very difficult to defend
I take takes continue improving with
tempo this case attacking rook he plays
here that rook g1 and when you're
attacking you just want to attack with
all your pieces I think that's a pretty
easy principle to apply in this case all
of White's pieces doing some job or
putting some pressure on the King side
Bishop e5 was played I think in this
position it's already a force twin
Knight take g7 take and I actually
sacrifice so if we count material I am
down the exchange but it is force mates
I'll leave it up to you guys
white to move may than three
very good Bishop f4 mates he resigned
one move before mates after Queen f7
gave up in this position but it's a nice
finish king of six Bishop f4 white being
down at rook here but just a complete
party on the Kings side for white so I
thought that was an interesting game
some kind of interesting sort of
tactical moments in the opening with the
whole scenario where he always wanted to
take on B - I got preventing him with
tactical opportunities so hopefully
maybe you can apply some of these ideas
to your own games if you play at the
London even if you don't play the London
some of the tactical and attacking ideas
can be applied from from any opening
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]